un fois intox avec vous Antoine fenaud
bonsoir Antoine bons direction l'Ukraine
ce soir avec une vidéo qui sème le doute
oui absolument une vidéo que vous allez
voir dans plusieurs publications à
commencer par celle-ci ouvertement pro
russe cette publication c'est une vidéo
du d'une scène de tournage on va y
revenir un petit peu plus tard tout
d'abord le contenu du tweet lui en
lui-même ouvertement pro russe en plus
d'être des nazis c'est aussi des
manipulateurs leur président est en
comédien ils savent le faire s'inding
c'est utilisateurs et il dit ils veulent
nous faire croire à la reddition d'un
équipage de char russe à noter également
que cette vidéo a également tournée
cette fois-ci en anglais avec un encore
plus de succès vous le voyez ici elle
cumule quasiment 100000 vues et lui
c'est utilisateur nous dit
Ursula Vander Leyens sur un ton très
ironique va envoyer des milliards
d'euros après avoir vu cette vidéo
dramatique ces dignes d'Hollywood la
vidéo en elle-même la voici c'est un
extrait qui dure une trentaine de
secondes environ et effectivement
qu'est-ce qu'on y voit une équipe de
tournage un caméraman
aussi avec un assistant et donc ensuite
la vidéo est bien se déroule avec des
effets de fumée notamment mis par un par
un autre membre de l'équipe de tournage
et donc l'action qui se déroule derrière
à noter et là c'est encore plus
intéressant que cette vidéo a également
circuler cette fois-ci côté ukrainien
mais sous une autre tonalité vous le
voyez par exemple avec ce tweet lui d'un
ukrainien donc et lui qu'est-ce qu'il
fait cette utilisateur lui il a relevé
l'inscription que vous voyez devant le
blindé l'inscription qui grosso modo dit
en russe direction Berlin le problème
c'est qu'il y a une faute d'orthographe
et que ça dit direction birlin donc
forcément c'est utilisateur lui s'en est
moqué à noter que ça a également été
repris par des officiels Ukrainiens
cette fois-ci sur leur compte telegram
c'est notamment le cas d'Anton
garachenko que vous voyez juste ici sont
sa page telegram donc lui il est
conseillé au ministère de l'Intérieur
ukrainien et il a il s'est également un
moqué de cette faute d'orthographe donc
dans ce commentaire ici Anthony et vous
avez retrouver l'origine de cette
extrait vidéo absolument nous avons
retrouvé ici un enfant intox l'origine
de cette vidéo elle est issue de ce
compte telegram ce compte telegramme
c'est celui d'un média ukrainien vous
retrouver les vidéos ici notamment avec
un une capture d'écran c'est le média
s'appelle doomskaïa et bien il précise
dans tout ce petit déroulé que vous
voyez juste ici qu'effectivement il
s'agit d'un film du tournage d'un film
par le réalisateur
Vladimir nagorni qui s'appelle Histoire
militaire
ukrainienne il a également cette
utilisateur lui ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'il a corrigé directement les
forces armées ukrainiennes qui avaient
repris les images de son film on va le
voir notamment ici ça c'est le poste
Facebook des forces armées
Ukrainiens qui a été corrigé depuis car
dans ce poste comme l'utilisateur que
vous avez vu avant les forces armées
Ukraine se moquaient de l'orthographe
très mauvaise des Russes en disant voilà
ils sont totalement
désorientés et bien vous le Vladimir les
a corrigés en disant non non il ne
s'agit pas de vraies images il s'agit
d'un film ce que ce qu'a fait donc les
forces armées ukrainiennes juste ici un
fond intox et bien ce réalisateur lui il
nous a partagé la vidéo en elle-même
plus complète de l'extrait que je vous
ai montré un petit peu plus avant et là
qu'est-ce qu'on voit vous l'avez vu au
tout début de la vidéo je vous le
remettre un petit peu en avant voilà
qu'est-ce qu'on veut on voit le clapman
que vous voyez donc juste ici avec
quelqu'un qui a forcément des de la
fausse fumée comme vu que c'est un
tournage de film et donc l'équipe de
tournage ici avec le fameux action qu'on
entend donc dans dans
tous les films et lui il précise et bien
le réalisateur que cette erreur
d'orthographe que vous avez vu et bien
c'était une erreur intentionnelle
évidemment pour se moquer des forces
russes donc et il faut dire que le film
en lui-même est source de confusion oui
absolument et c'est ça qui est
finalement assez intéressant c'est que
ce film ukrainien histoire donc de
guerre en Ukraine et bien a été réalisé
en tout cas est en train d'être tourné
avec de vrai soldats ukrainiens et
d'ailleurs le réalisateur dont je vous
ai parlé un petit peu plus tôt Vladimir
nagorni il avait fait un appel à
candidature ici sur Facebook où vous le
voyez juste ici c'était en septembre
dernier il disait voilà les tours le
tournage va commencer le 21 septembre il
nous avons besoin donc de bras il a
également partagé sur facebook également
plusieurs extraits de ce tournage que
vous voyez juste ici nous avons fait un
petit montage de de ces séquences et
notamment ici où il dit et bien nous
avons tourné en conditions réelles nous
avons tourné dans un vrai champ de mine
en plein milieu ou quasiment des combats
avec également cette séquence que vous
voyez juste ici il faut dire également
que bien il va il va réaliser ce
réalisateur trois films au total les
acteurs donc ce je lisais ce sont des
soldats et un média ukrainien l'a
également évoqué vous le voyez juste ici
ce média il s'appelle verychi Kiev et
nous précise de quel type de soldats il
s'agit statique qui date là du 28
octobre vous le voyez juste ici et on
voit ici la fiche de promotionnel du
film il dit et bien que les 127ème
brigades des forces armées ukrainiennes
de kerkhov ainsi que les 122e et 126e
brigades des forces armées cette fois-ci
de dessin ont participé également à la
réalisation de ce film qui donc met en
scène la bataille de kerkhov vous l'avez
donc compris il s'agit donc d'une vidéo
ouvertement il s'agit donc d'un film et
le réalisateur n'avait absolument pas
l'intention d'induire en erreur sur
l'origine de cette vidéo en revanche les
prorus sont son donnés à cœur joie vous
l'avez vu pour la détourner et les
Ukrainiens seront également tombés dans
le panneau si l'on peut dire merci
beaucoup Antoine fenou pour votre
éclairage à fond intox à retrouver sur
France 24.com on marque une pose dans
Paris direct on se retrouve dans
quelques minutes pour le journal à tout
de suite
[Musique]